depuis son ouverture en 2011 la filière
bois de goyavier a permis à une centaine
d'agents d'acquérir des savoirs de base
soutenue par le conseil général
la filière est en plein développement
objectif répondre aux missions de la
collectivité en matière d'insertion
professionnelle et lutter contre
l'envahissement des milieux naturels par
une peste végétale une insertion par
l'économie réservés en priorité aux
bénéficiaires du rsa
jean-françois hoarau un responsable du
développement revient sur sa vision de
l'insertion professionnelle pour moi la
base c'est cesser de l'employabilité les
mettre sur le marché de l'emploi
après les gens izard rep avide de
compétences
ils le découvrent ils découvrent le
métier où les métiers ils s'approprient
les outils ils produisent avec
avec nous et le sourire c'est que soit
en fin de course après l'heure
leur contrat qui va de 6 mois à 1 an et
on va dire soit il part dans un autre
service à appliquer ce qu'ils ont appris
ici
soit ils deviennent
salarié d'une entreprise externe où ils
créent eux mêmes leurs petites
entreprises avec leurs savoirs de base
plus le complément qu'on peut leur
donner
arrivé au sein de la filière par le
biais d'un contrat d'apprentissage
emmanuel boyer a acquis un savoir qu'il
entend mettre à profit la justice était
très mon entreprise 5 200 de l'affilié
un bogey vais aussi utiliser cette
matière là que normalement espèces
végétales à la réunion
avec ses petits gars là je pourrais
réussir ici demain passer le cap de
l'expérimentation la filière bois de
goyavier se développe le mobilier urbain
et notamment les abris voyageurs
disséminés dans l'île ont d'abord
remporté l'adhésion du public en avril
les portes ouvertes de l'atelier ont
remporté un franc succès une opération
séduction qui se poursuivra avec
l'inauguration prochaine de l'espace
redley où sont exposés les objets issus
de la filière
désormais la production issue des
ateliers et destinés à la vente
une nécessité pour faire de la filière
un véritable outil autonome et pérenne
d'insertion par l'économie la régie de
vente a été mis en place cette année est
opérationnelle depuis le mois d'août on
a le le droit de vendre à travers cette
régie vente du conseil général qui se
situe à l'espace réglé dans le bas de la
rivière hudson dans quelques semaines
les points de vente sont amenés à se
multiplier
après les collectivités et les
particuliers et les professionnels
misent eux aussi sur le bois de goyavier
mais on cible au surtout aussi les
professionnels les groupes genre
khairi et europe qui veulent par exemple
des bordures jardin des l'accessoire
jardin ou de distance il parce que c'est
un produit pays qui veulent vendre chez
eux quoi sur leur sur leurs étalages
utiliser les investissements de la
collectivité comme des leviers pour
favoriser l'insertion agir sur l'emploi
et appuyer la création d'entreprise les
possibilités offertes par le
développement de la filière sont
multiples elles rencontrent enfin la
volonté du conseil général de lutter
contre une peste végétale en la
transformant en véritable bois pays au
service de la collectivité
on remercie le conseil général se doit